[Music]
hello and welcome to sidetrack your
sci-fi tv a movie channel
i am here at the moment to do a very
impromptu last minute live video because
i made a mistake
and i need to apologize to you i think i
actually need to apologize to brad
wright which
is really embarrassing um but basically
i did a video earlier in the week that
some of you guys might have seen and in
the video i basically said that brad
wright um is in hollywood is actually in
um los angeles at the mgm headquarters
having meetings on tuesday
in the video i also said that the source
that i speak to at mgm had seen brad
wright in the building on monday
brad wright then messaged me
which is a bit like being told off by
your dad and somebody you look up to
basically the creator of my favorite tv
show ever
to tell me that he's not in la and this
isn't true basically
um
so
initially i thought that that message on
youtube was probably fake i get a lot of
fakeness she's got a lot of [ __ ]
message stuff people trying to wind me
up so i thought it's probably not true i
then checked his twitter feed and no it
was true um he isn't in l.a or he says
he's internally um and he's not
attending these meetings
so i immediately messaged my source
with a
what the f in hell is going on why have
you told me this
um
basically there are a couple of
possibilities here on how this
happened
first of all
um
basically this guy this source person is
is is
[ __ ] he's not he's not true he
doesn't know anything um i do get a lot
of information from people that i can't
verify and i don't share it because i
can't verify it in this case i do know
that the chap in question does work for
mgm is from california i've checked as
much as possible that he is who he says
he is
so i genuinely believe he he at least
believed me he was bleeding
this could be misinformation it could be
information that's been leaked
purposefully
marvel do this all the time they they
leak information through different
sources just to keep people guessing
um but that's to be honest probably
quite unlikely as well it seems a bit
conspiracy theory-ish
um to think that that's happened but
it's possible i suppose
the other possibility is that brad
wright was actually being dishonest but
that is really unlikely that he actually
is at these meetings isn't supposed to
tell anyone i've let the cat out of the
bag do my video
so
he has tried to nip it in the bud i
think that is incredibly unlikely for
one he's canadian i don't think they are
capable of lying but also he wouldn't go
out of his way
to actually like go yeah no this isn't
true
um if if if it was so i really don't
think that's true um another thing was
they said those maybe he isn't in la but
maybe he's going to join these meetings
by zoom
somebody asked him out on twitter and he
said no that's also not the case
so i really locked down on my source to
ask him what the hell is going on
first of all
on the brad right actually seeing brad
wright so it says are you certain it was
him and he went i i was i was certain it
was him
but he was wearing a mask
and i'm like what
so you're not certain it was him then if
this if guy's wearing a mask you've seen
him across the room you're not certain
with him and that's what he told me he
said he was ninety percent certainly
seeing me saw him across the room
so right
the meetings that were penciled in are
you certain his name was on these
meetings to to attend these meetings and
he's adamant he was
but i basically think i know what's
happened
this is in my opinion but i think this
has happened because to be honest i've
asked him again really no seriously that
this is important and he's not come back
to me
but
what i think has happened is i think
he's trying to tell me the truth do you
remember these sources that i speak to
mgm they talk to me because
um i listen for one but also they told
me because they're massive fans of
stargate they love stargate as much as
we do so they want this information to
get out they want their opinions to
connect
um these are rumors that go around any
office building again these people that
i've talked to they're not high up
executives or anything they're they're
normal in some cases normal people that
work in and around the building
so
rumors go around the building as well i
try to tell you when these things are
rumors
i didn't actually believe him when he
told me he'd seen brad right so i tried
to sort of when i did this video that
i've now deleted by the way and because
i don't if it's not true i don't want it
on the channel
um
but you know i i said to him i wasn't
really sure
um so i said this is what he said he
said he saw it from across the room he
has spoken to brad right before so he
was nine percent certain of i wasn't
sure
um
so basically i think the rooms do go
around office blocks if anybody's ever
worked in office you know they do i will
share them with you because they're
rumors that come from the mgm building
they come from the mgm company so i
think they're worth sharing this it's
worth the risk to share them
in this case it's bit me in the ass
but it's not all bad news
because when brad white did message me
he also said that he's sure these
meetings are actually happening
he's just not been invited to them
so that gets me back to what i think's
happened i think this chap this source
has seen that there are a bunch of
stargate meetings penciled in
they were booking grooms or whatever to
to have these meetings
i think he is somehow seen brad wright's
name on those
sheets
i wonder if he's like says brad wright
stargate or something like that and he's
seen that but he's seen brad wright's
name somewhere on these these things and
he is assumed brad knight would be
attending these meetings
he's then seen some bloke
who we thought was brad right put two
and two together and made six and told
me who then looks like a complete idiot
on a live video
but
the underlying point is this that brad
wright even agrees that these meetings
are happening
so that is the good news on this bit
that at very least
the source is accurate on that bit
he just got over excited about brad
wright attending them um it sounds to me
from what broderick said on his very
short message but someone that he
wouldn't stand them anyway but i'm i may
be reading between the lines there a
little bit
so that's what basically i think has
happened
i'm very annoyed because i look like a
complete idiot
but it can't be helped because at the
end of the day i try to get information
out to you as quickly as possible
sometimes that information is not going
to be as accurate as i'd like i do make
mistakes on these videos sometimes
because i'm trying to get my to as
quickly as possible but for example when
joseph melozi tweeted that he'd seen the
script
and he had his light reading over the
weekend the sims script that brad right
has produced
um a script that brad wright says he
actually wrote nearly a year ago and i
was told was edited and um was only
actually seen by amazon people about a
month or six weeks ago but um broadway
says he wrote it a year ago
um
i had that information on my channel
within 24 hours
gateworld and other channels like
podcasting on this took nearly a week
um
um
i could have ignored this
information um i actually really did
i've actually had other information
before now that i have ignored for
example i was once told that amazon had
agreed to buy two series of stargate i
knew that wasn't true
um i didn't share it i knew that amazon
and mgm still have not made a decision
on stargate at the time i was told that
i knew amazon and mgm were considering
at least two different projects and had
not even definitely decided to go with
brad wright's project i'm now told that
they have
and the bride rights project is the only
one they're even considering
so i knew that information wasn't true
so i didn't share it with you guys
and it was also from a source i didn't
know particularly well
so i could have ignored this
i think the reason why i didn't was
because he was telling me two things at
the same time if he hadn't have said to
me that he'd seen brad in the building
the day before i don't think i'd have
gone with it i don't think i did on the
video i might have put a comment on the
community page just saying the rumor is
um which i actually did it first before
i decided to do the video
but i wouldn't have done but it's
because i had both bits of information
but anyway
made a mistake i apologize to brad
wright because i wasted his time i've
wasted other people's time and i hate
that
but
silver lining
brad white did confirm that he is
absolutely certain these meetings are
happening
um they're happening this week
and hopefully we'll start getting
something a bit more concrete to come
out
about our favorite tv show really really
soon so it's just a quick video
basically to make that apology to
correct the information because i don't
want anything out there that's not true
and to
fingers crossed
um bradford won't tell me off again
because it wasn't a nice degree at all
better
thanks guys
if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe do all that business um
i'm not gonna say anything else because
i feel like a complete idiot
thanks guys please stay safe i'll see
you next time
[Music]
you